i've had times in my life where i've
thought too much about regrets and stuff
in my life right yeah we've talked about
that some in the past like looking in
the past too much right or attaching
myself to the past was there is there
has there been anything along your
journey that you've kind of regretted
and then how do you deal with regret i
mean individual choices and mistakes
yeah but ultimately you learn from those
so like no because like even the regrets
the bad things or the stupid things you
learn not to do bad things or stupid
things
you know those all those things are
beneficial in some way if you can get
through them
you know
you know if you like
did something that required that
resulted in someone's death or some
something horrible like that yeah it'd
be terrible regret
but i've been very fortunate that that
hasn't happened but
the dumb [ __ ] that i've done or the bad
mistakes that i've made they've taught
me you know you learn
like that's why failure is so important
like failing and [ __ ] up and making
mistakes it's very important that's how
you learn let's see the bad feeling that
you get from something that you
shouldn't have done or wish you didn't
do or wish you did better like
especially failing at something where
you half-assed it and you just feel like
a [ __ ] loser like that just teaches
you
it teaches you to get your [ __ ] together
well you have such a good ability to
learn from those things some people i
think kind of repeat you know it's just
like it gets repetitive for some people
that's dangerous yeah it's dangerous to
dwell on past mistakes because people
sort of define themselves by the worst
moments that they've ever had and if
that's the case like some people are
stuck in high school
you know they're stuck in failures that
they had like when they're first getting
jobs and they always think that they're
a loser and they they don't like the
feeling of failure so they keep low
expectations so that they never have to
feel that
you got to get through it you got to get
through
bad feelings you got to get through um
you got to get through failure it's very
important and you get through it by just
picking yourself back up and moving
forward and going but it's hard for a
lot of people because they that sting
they never get over it the feeling of
failure and they don't have a good
support system like good friends like
having a good community of friends is
very very important because you could
feel like down like if you've been a
girl broke up with you and you feel like
you're the worst you're a [ __ ] loser
like you're a piece of [ __ ] but then you
go out with your friends and you have a
few laughs and next thing you know
you're laughing and you're like i'm all
right
we'll be all right then maybe you meet a
new lady yeah yeah and she like picks
you up and you're like oh we're gonna be
okay and then you learn from the last
mistakes yeah that's life it's just
those feelings of failure are so hard
they're so hard to get over and they
they overwhelm people and some people
can't get past them and then every time
some new thing comes up when you have to
rise to the occasion you have to perform
you think about that time you failed and
it [ __ ] your head up man you think i'm
a [ __ ] loser i can't do this i'm
gonna fail i'm gonna [ __ ] up you know
like bombing like how many times have
you had a bad set and you're like god
damn it i suck at comedy i can't do this
i can't do this i suck at comedy that's
just it i just suck
and then you define yourself that way
and you got to get over it
yeah i do know thankfully you never have
too bad in a row either which is kind of
interesting well you learn from that one
and you like coming out guns blazing for
the next show yeah
yeah maybe it activates some senses in
you did you feel like you learned that
from somebody or did you always just
have that kind of intuition when it
comes to that kind of stuff i think i
learned it from martial arts because you
you get your ass kicked and like you
don't want to get your ass kicked again
you either quit fighting or you learn
how to get a lot better you know and
then you get your ass kicked in training
which happens all the time
and you know you learn from those
mistakes you learn you know like maybe
you're stationary too much or maybe you
telegraph too much or maybe you you got
tired you haven't been doing your cardio
like
those those failures that you have for
martial arts are so consequential
because you get hurt like you physically
get punished and then you don't want
that to happen again so you got to be
either quit or get way better
i like that and that's great for a lot
of my listeners a lot of guys you know
or just you know a lot of guys um
just trying to keep going in their in
their lives yeah with everybody and my
listeners your listeners anybody who's
listening to anything just people out
there yeah that's why there's so many
self-help books that's why there's so
many motivational documentaries and
motivational instagram pages is because
people need stuff like that they need
something and generally the best version
of it is coming from someone who's
experienced [ __ ] ups and got through it
yeah you know
yeah i appreciate it man you know you're
like a kind of like a library i was
thinking about the other the other day
in a weird way you're like kind of like
a like a library you know that's
interesting
how am i a librarian because you just
have all this information that's passed
through you and you're able to like kind
of you're almost like a cleaners at the
cleaners if you ask a question then it
goes and gets the information and brings
it to the front you know and it's like
wrapped up kind of it's cool that's a
funny way it's a nice skill man because
i was even listening to an old episode
of ours and there was information and
like kind of suggestions and guidance
you shared with me in there that were
still resonating with me today so it's
just pretty cool
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you